now there's no reason to be got to take
out every night when you can dedicate
ten minutes to cook an amazing dish
that's why I'm putting the challenge out
there to Mir to see what you can do with
seafood in just 10 minutes
Mir I hope there's some Puerto Rican
Flair in this amazing dish welcome to
Ramsay and ten hi guys welcome to Ramsay
and ten today I'm taking one of
America's biggest food crazies right now
okay and I'm marrying it with big out
which is the rice that gets stuck to the
bottom of the pot and it's really famous
in Puerto Rico my family actually fights
over it at the end of the night vamos
here I have some leftover rice from the
night before you just want it to be a
little warm for when we season it and
the way we're gonna do that is with some
rice vinegar it's about two tablespoons
a tablespoon of sugar and a little bit
of salt that vinegar is not gonna get me
but but yeah sorry
even vinegar won't stop me from
completing this challenge so now that we
have the rice seasoned you can taste it
just to make sure perfect and don't
worry I'm doing this by taste but you
can find the recipe below what that
seasoning does also the sugar is it
makes it sticky so then we get a really
nice perfect rice cake so I'm just
putting a little coconut oil into this
pan just enough to cover the bottom
we're gonna go straight with the rice
right in and that's what you want
medium-high and you want to hear that
sizzle
[Music]
so water prevents the rice from sticking
to my hands then I can get it really
flat so the other side Chris is really
nicely too alright so we're gonna leave
that there crisping up and while that
cooks we're gonna move on to our sushi
grade ahi tuna if you can't find sushi
grade ahi tuna you can use salmon
instead and we're just gonna slice it
into small little cubes this dish is
really impressive because it plays with
textures a lot like the rice is kind of
chewy in the center and it's crispy and
then the tuna is really nice and savory
but it doesn't feel heavy it feels
really fresh it's a nice Island meal
which is
doesn't really have to be perfect times
not on my side right now and I know for
Millennials and for you know busy
families it probably isn't either so we
go straight in a bowl with the tuna we
have some Mayo I'm just gonna do a
little bit go to young which is a
fermented chili paste but if you don't
find it you can just do sriracha instead
it'll work just fine some toasted sesame
oil I'm gonna check my rice which should
be on this there and then the best way
to flip this is have a plate you just
put the plate right over the pan all
right perfect
so then we're just gonna slide it back
on to the pan and if it's not perfect
it's fine it's gonna get covered up with
the tuna anyway then we'll just slide it
right back onto the pan
all right so turn already rights is
almost ready
we're just gonna cut some chives slice
our avocado and we'll be ready to go
so I'm actually gonna fan this avocado
so it looks really impressive it's gonna
peel it nicely all the way to the end
but you can just cut it into cubes it'll
taste the same and then what you do is
you sort of push it away from you so it
fans out all right and this should be
almost ready here so time is almost done
but the rice needs to get a little
crispy and it's just a matter of putting
everything together I've never cooked
bouquet on Hell's Kitchen but I'm sure I
would have won another challenge if I
would up slide it right on the plate
going to now
all over the surface this dish is
amazing by yourself or if you're
entertaining to share with someone else
your significant other but it's just
versatile avocado
season your avocado and there you go oh
that was close Gordon that's how you
make a Puerto Rican poke a and just
under ten minutes thank you so much for
joining me leave a comment below and
tell me how long it took you to make my
pokey dish and please don't forget to
subscribe to a Gordon's Channel you
don't tell that to a Puerto Rican woman
[Laughter]